-Last week, President Trump
invoked his emergency economic
powers to ban
the digital app TikTok.
Here to talk about it
is our new writer, Jeff Wright.
-What it do, Seth?
-Hey, Jeff.
So what do you think about
the President banning TikTok?
-I hate this.
Someone has to do something.
-Oh, wow! So, I didn't realize
you'd be that upset.
-Of course I'm upset!
I'm a young person.
Imagine if someone
took your Metamucil, Seth.
You'd be mad, too.
-I'm not that old.
-Are you on TikTok?
-I'm on Twitter.
-Oh, like the President.
-I'm not as old
as the President.
-Oh, good for you.
You sound like my grandma.
That's a great attitude to have.
Look, like a lot
of young people,
I spend a lot of time on TikTok.
It's really important to me.
And I think this ban
is an attack on the youth.
-Oh, interesting.
Why do you think ending
TikTok accounts
is an attack on the youth?
-Because that's something
Donald Trump
has never had before.
-A TikTok account?
-Youth.
Trump has never been young
in his life.
The man was born old.
Look at this picture.
Look at that shirt.
He's 4 years old,
and he looks like he's headed
to a parent/teacher conference.
-Well, what about the fact
that the app can be used
by oppressive governments
and counterintelligence
to gather information
and surveil Americans?
-I don't understand
these old words you're using.
Try saying "swag"
at the end of your sentence.
-What about the fact
that the app could be used
to spy on Americans? Swag.
-Ohh! That's what
you were trying to say?
Look, Seth, this is America.
In 2020, we don't have
any intelligence.
We're running around maskless,
coughing on each other
at Outback Steakhouse.
We dumb as hell.
The only information that could
be collected from our country
is what NOT to do.
Besides, this isn't about
data or intelligence.
This is about the President
getting roasted.
-Oh, so you think Trump's
decision to ban is based on
the amount of people
who make fun of him on TikTok?
-Seth, what is the only thing
worse than being teased?
-Being teased by people
younger than you
on an app you don't understand.
-Exactly, Seth.
TikTok has been around and owned
by China for four years.
But now suddenly
when Trump realizes
he's being roasted on it,
he has a problem with it?
It's clear.
There's a connection.
It's like how I heard you wore
shorts to the office one time,
and everyone made fun
of your bird legs so bad,
no one's allowed to wear shorts
to the office anymore.
-[ Stammers ]
That's not true.
-So I can wear shorts
to the office?
-No one's going to the office
right now because of COVID.
-But I can wear shorts
when we come back?
-Well...I think it'll probably
be too cold for shorts then.
-What if winter shorts
is my thing?
-Look, I don't have bird legs!
Okay?!
-See? You're mad that you
got teased. And so is Trump.
I'd be mad, too, if an app
that sounds like a fun way
to tell time
filled with people dancing
was actually being used
to make fun of me.
Old people are crazy sensitive.
Almost as sensitive
as they are indecisive.
-Indecisive?
-Yes.
First they tell us,
"Go outside more,"
and, "Get off your screens."
Then you guys cancel outside
for what seems like forever.
So we stay inside
and use TikTok,
but now that's getting banned?
At this point, I'm like, "What
more do you want from me?!"
Talk to 'em, Seth!
Use your old words
to convince him.
-I don't think I can convince
Trump to do anything.
-What about when you convinced
him to run for president?
-I, you know, I don't think
it was me who did that.
-You would think Trump
would love TikTok
since he has so much in common
with it.
They're both influenced
by shady foreign elements,
and they both make you
scream at your phone.
-What about the fact
that China may be using TikTok's
increasing influence
on young minds
to push communist propaganda?
-I don't understand
these old words you're using.
Try saying "swag"
at the end again.
-All right.
What about the fact that China
may be using TikTok as a means
to push propaganda? Swag.
-Oh! You got to lead
with "swag," Seth.
And so what if China's
pushing their narratives?
Food ads do it all the time.
No matter how many times
they show me
that cold-looking,
floppy-ass sandwich,
when I get hungry,
I'm never thinking,
"Hm. I should go to Arby's."
-Sounds like you're really upset
about this.
-Yes! TikTok was all I had.
-You still have Facebook.
-Again, I don't understand
these old words.
-Jeff Wright, everybody.